- I'm creating a website
with all the ammunition
that a cyberbully
will need to attack.
I'm not just feeding the trolls,
I'm rolling out an
all-you-can-eat buffet.
After uploading some of
my childhood pictures
along with my email
and phone number
I offered $50 as bait
and posted my challenge
to Reddit and 4chan, ground zero
for the internet's
most vicious trolls.
Let's see what happens.
Within hours the
hate came flying in.
At first it was insults
about my intelligence,
a few about my age slash looks,
some made no sense at all.
Then came the threats.
Basically, dude,
people will attack
your family to get to you.
It's best if you don't
make a public statement
that you're impenetrable.
I carried on with
the rest of my day
as the attacks kept coming.
The ext morning I discovered
my Instagram and Twitter
accounts were hacked.
After an eagle-eyed
troll noticed my password
in my challenge photo.
A password my
assistant, Jasmine,
assured me was out of focus.
Then the memes hit.
(light, intense music)
The cyberbullies were obsessed
with one of my photos,
trying to to one up each other
by portraying me as a sex dildo.
But one troll rose
above the rest,
slamming me with nonstop images,
memes, and unfortunately,
poetry.
I responded to the troll
and said if he wanted my $50
he would have to
appear on camera.
He agreed but only if he
could choose the location.
He's given me coordinates
and we're almost there.
He had complete
home-court advantage,
and I was unsure what
sport we were even playing.
Follow the light, cuck.
Can't even spell cock right.
There he is, there he is.
I now had a rare chance to
confront a troll face to face.
Hey man.
- Hey, shit.
- How should I address you?
- Lol Jessie.
- Little Jessie?
- Lol, do this shit for lol's,
lol's sec, lol's hacker
group, fuck yeah.
So I said cyberbully
me and here are
some of the things you did.
You sent a picture of someone
holding a bottle of pills.
It says jon dore's libtard
agenda on the pills.
- Yeah.
- So you think I'm
liberal and retarded?
- Yeah.
- Here's another one.
You posted what
looks like a tweet
coming from Kim Jong-Un's
personal account.
It says got my first
intercontinental
ballistic missile working,
where should I
send my first nuke?
And then you have a
poll, Jon's front door.
- Yeah.
- Sixty-eight percent.
- I'm gonna take
issue with this.
I live in the United States now.
If you were to
nuke my front door
you'd also already be nuking
the United States of America.
- Is it going to happen?
- Yeah, 68% of people
do want it to hit,
oh is this all fake?
You didn't actually
put out a poll?
- No.
- oh.
So then you've gone into
some poetry, if I may.
- I did.
That one I'm proud of.
- So this is what you wrote.
What's true of you
is you're mediocre,
but you covered
up like a choker,
but you're still a choker.
Notice you just rhymed
choker with choker?
- Yeah, cause I used
a double meaning.
- That's an air ball.
- How old are you?
- How old do you think I am?
- Like 49?
- All right, let's just move on.
What advice would
you give to kids
who are being trolled
or bullied online?
- Keep your sanity
by going insane.
I mean I was a little
kid getting bullied
and I toughened up.
- Okay, let's say your
trolling made me freak out
and blow my head off in
a microwave or something?
- I don't hold personal
responsibility for your choices.
- Do you think you'll
be a troll forever?
- Yeah, hell yeah.
If anyone's gonna save the
world from a big brother
type reality, it's gonna be
the motherfucking trolls.
- Have you ever felt remorseful
about any of the
trolling you've done?
- No.
- None at all?
- Zero percent.
Have you ever heard of
Aristotle's extreme of means?
- Totally I have, but for the
viewers explain it to them.
- So in order to
correct a virtue
you try to practice the extreme
antithesis of that virtue
'cause you don't find virtue
on one extreme or the other.
Virtue, virtueness isn't
binary, it's balanced.
Yeah, that's Aristotle's--
- Extreme of means.
- Yeah, exactly.
Well, you did win the
cyberbully challenge hands down
so I do owe you $50.
Actually, will you give
me an apology first
before I give it to you?
- Fuck no, what?
- For the horrible
things you said online?
- You can get a handshake
and maybe a bro hug.
- All right, $50,
handshake, bro hug.
- No, no, that's a
full ass fucking hug.